eh bien le bonjour ou est-ce qu'on est
ici aujourd'hui alors non n'est pas la
maison nom n'est pas au studio on est
dans le sud de la france on n'est pas
très loin de montpellier pic saint loup
c'est pas ça vous parle alors au delà
d'être une bonne bouteille c'est une
montagne mais c'est pas qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui ce qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui c'est parler de
reconditionner on va parler ici d'une
entreprise s'appelle sophie groupe vous
connaissez peut-être pas mais vous
connaissez peut-être leur marque
s'appelle smart ils viennent
reconditionnés des smartphones est ce
qu'on va faire aujourd'hui on va aller
par là dans l'entrée on va aller visiter
l'usiné on va les voir comment se
reconditionner smartphone comme ans marc
travail qu'est ce qu'ils proposent leur
valeur les garanties l'entreprise c'est
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui a réalisé en
partenariat avec smart mais
rassurez-vous smart on va les prendre en
valais ce coup et on va aller voir ce
qui se passe et vous allez voir on a
déjà regardé c'est intéressant
les produits arrivent et ils passent ici
dans le tunnel de désinfection lampe uv
dangereux pour les yeux donc on met pas
une tête là dedans on regarde pas ça
permet de désinfecter et dourdan
produits clean pour pouvoir être traités
quant aux smartphones arrive la première
chose à faire c'est de le charger et
pour charger espace juste ici juste et
simon à carole roy carroll fera très
bien merci bon alors explique moi ce qui
se passe ici en fait donc on a reçu des
téléphones ouais on lisait identifiés et
on les mange change donc ton smartphone
là il est déjà chargé alors ici on va le
brancher sur notre logiciel va donc là
on va effacer toutes les données
personnelles du téléphone est bien plus
de données l'utilisateur du tri du tout
ok c'est grâce à ça on va savoir si son
icloud blacklisté baptiste et ça veut
dire quoi la piste est volée perdu
d'accord donc ça veut dire en fait je
vérifie que le numéro imei qu'il est
clean si elles ont moins de soucis ça
nous est indiqué et une fois que
l'ordinateur a fait son qu'ils sont
petits boulots ou non sans une petite
étiquette comme ça et sur cette
étiquette on a le modèle la couleur les
jeunes la cité fondée et gris sidéral
256 numéro ému ou les numéros de série
aussi oui mais retirer aussi la dernière
version du téléphone ok et la batterie
après je le défends je le mets dedans
ouais et après ils parlent de l'autre
côté au déballage
[Musique]
donc là on verra par loïc alors loïc
caisses qui se vident ce qu'est ce qui
se passe ce soir mais pas rigolo de
natation alors à quand le déballage way
ou le gradé ça veut dire quoi le grade
insider qui va donner en fait une tuée a
qualifié le smartphone voilà moi je vais
regarder l'état esthétique du téléphone
ouais je vais enregistrer les défauts
que je constate et ensuite le logiciel
va déterminer un grade sur l'appareil
dont contre moi ça veut dire que là en
fait on a quoi on a un iphone une en
plein air phone 8 donc je vais rentrer
les informations du téléphone dans le
système ouais donc son modèle sa couleur
les îliens 64 giga en alien nuit on a
numéro série de signaux d une loquet et
ensuite mais je vais faire l'état
esthétique de l'appareil donc j'ai
regardé les trois phases la face avant
donc là on voit qu'on fait là il est
quand même bien marquer soleil là il est
bien marquée donc on a beaucoup de micro
rayures on a des rayures et on a des
rayures prononcer ce qu'on appelle
prononcer ces grosses rayures les eaux
profondes voilà donc la face avant pour
moi c'est des rayures prononcer et c'est
quoi je veux tu as tout une nomenclature
ça correspond aux quels critères s'est
divisée entre partir on à la face avant
le contour et la face arrière et après
ça reprend tous les défauts qu'on peut
retrouver sur les téléphones voile et
après on peut avoir des casses de
l'écaillage donc l'écaillage ça va être
sur certains modèles ça va être la
peinture qui va se décoller sous la
vitre ok alors le contour on a des
taches blanches donc là je vais m en
usure normale donc sur la face arrière
on voit que sur le bord il ya des
rayures là des milliers cros dreyer un
petit peu partout mais là bon on va le
faire passer en face arrière ir et une
fois que je terminais je valide est
lâché mon étiquette qui va sortir avec
le grade de l'appareil c'est le grain de
sel en entrée ça veut dire que si par
exemple on d'écran est abîmée l'écran va
être changée après est potentiellement
le grade pour échanger voilà
un type d'info les trois grades à grade
à c'est comme neuf le grade b c'est du
très bon état et le grade c c'est du bon
état comme ça vous savez tout parce que
c'est pas les grappes qui apparaît sur
le site internet de smart d'ailleurs le
site de smart qu'est ce qu'on fait on va
jeter un petit coup d'oeil vous avez le
lien en bas dans la description
on vient avant miel rien n'égale pas
pourquoi je tape bien sûr vos dur
aujourd'hui c'est passé c'est mon truc
qu'est ce qui se passe mais gagnent chez
toi raconte moi quand les téléphones qui
arrive ouais donc qui viennent les
déballages ils arrivent ici nous
hissions quand on les teste donc on a
plusieurs points de test à tester fort y
en a une quarantaine d'accueil à des
tests qui seront automatiquement tout
seul du style le magnétomètre
l'accéléromètre aussi le gps qui se
teste tout seul aussi et après on a
testé cette affaire manuellement pour
tester les boutons donc nous avons salah
qui grise et ouais donc là quand on va
venir appuyer dessus il vient de
disparaître des corps donc ça veut dire
qu'il soit fonctionnel qui ont été
testées exactement c'est exactement ça
le capteur de proximité voilà donc liens
fonctionnels ou qu'après on vient de
tester aussi l'affichage donc la dalle
lcd donc l etat et les cds rémanence
aussi à des tâches là nous voyons qu'une
belle tâche en haut là bas il pas mal
cela voilà donc ça ça va être une panne
une panneaux lcd donc ça de dire à
l'étranger en fait voilà exactement nous
avons l'écran qui cassent et aussi donc
ça séparer ça ils vont changer l'écran
nous avons aussi le châssis qu'étendu
donc l'appareil et vont changer le
châssis mais l'écran qui est décollée
aussi il
il a pris chercher le voilà celui ci va
manger way sinon le reste il est nickel
l'appel là on va tester l'écouteur
interne
le port l'heure il est très bien allô
allô allô allô allô allô allô allô là
j'aurai coûte voilà donc là c'était
parfait nous avons aussi les caméras
conteste si l'auto focus il marche bien
s'il n'y a pas de tâche c'est tout testé
à la main c'est tout testé à la main le
flash on voit qu'il y ait l'autofocus il
y à aussi l'appareil avant si c'est pas
floues s'il n'y a pas de tâche après
nous testons aussi le tactile test jack
les haut parleurs et après c'est le
désimlockage ouais il est désimlocké et
la version de capacité le vibreur qui
vibre très bien qu'après on teste le
data même si ça a déjà été fait à la
réception là on a fait tout le processus
de test jen hefford jennifer jennifer
comment est ce que tu vas mais ça va bon
alors toi tu reparler téléphone c'est ça
tu peux m'expliquer on l'a par exemple
c'est quoi ta quoi dans la main là j'ai
un iphone ixair d'accord et les petits
soucis sur un souci c'est qu'ils aient
un point lumineux au niveau du lcd
d'accord donc là tu fais quoi tu vas
changer lé tro laz effectivement j'ai
changer l'écran totalement donc l'as far
à l'ouvrir procéder au choix en avant
les composants qui sont sur l'écran elle
me remplacer moi je suis très mauvais
mais dix doigts dont je sais rien faire
je vais apprendre des choses tu vois ça
va être la guerre
mondiale et en plus c'est la ventouse
mois il flex un roi c'est incroyable ati
rage et la toile qui divise pas mais
j'enlève les 10 min à l'homme pour
pouvoir ouvrir directement donc un
devoir lever de plaques donc j'ai
plusieurs petites vis il faut faire très
attention c'est tout le monde une
précision incroyable c'est ça va j'ai
enlevé les plaques on voit effectivement
les nappes de connexion d'écran hockey
et je vais aller enlever un premier lieu
la connexion avec la batterie le plus
important avec une histoire celle qui
fait pas producteur à l'écran a été
enlevé je vais aller enlever ce qu'on
appelle d'écouteurs interne nous parler
c'est le tout petit fils alors pareille
à une adhérence niveau là on fait
d'avoir un père toute façon fait on
récupère en ligne allemand parce que sur
celui ci ait pas de témoigner
d'oxydation nous allons devoir en 7 v
pour le repositionner sur le nouveau
très important important ce qui
effectivement si l'achat de clients le
tombeau dans l'eau ou autre il se casse
ou autre ça nous permet effectivement de
voir si le téléphone est oxydé à partir
de là on fixe le tout mais on concède
remontage de celui ci
la collection la batterie gratuit le but
mais te regarde s'ils marchent à leur
tour fermé
jaxaay ici on fait de la micro soudure
ce smartphone est plus courant c'est de
la réparation de tous les connecteurs le
consiste tout petit quand la connexion
entre l'écran et les partenaires sur ce
téléphone par exemple j'ai pas de carte
est un partenaire tactile donc ces deux
connecteurs qui en cause le connecteur
ide et lun comment ça se passait les
procédures d'abord je détecte les
pingouins avec les micros hockey après
jeu de soude avec stationné à l'air
chaud voilà je me la température ok 400°
nickel pour laisser marquer et après si
c'est nécessaire jeu utilise le bien sûr
le fait un soleil voilé pour
vérification ces deux blocs
d'alimentation mais c'est tout ok je te
laisse faire
[Musique]
bravo les smartphones ont fait le tour
de l'usiné il arrive jusqu'à toi alors
celui là tu peux me racontant que le cas
l'histoire il avait jusqu'à arriver ici
alors celui d'elne a été déballée bon le
tactile et et casting a été réparée
encore une réparation chez moi s'est
passé par le test final aussi qui a
vérifié avec 6 fonctionner donc toi tu
fais pas maintenant tu fais la dernière
vérification à raison de 10 soit
expédiée qui parle de celle ci tout
dhabi la main c'était ma phrase on le
fait ou
vérifier si tout est bon dans la filiale
échangé à dix jours voilà le tactile a
été changé ok on va retirer toutes ces
étiquettes les l'ombre alors un petit
peu beaucoup pas vérifié son petit
tiroir s'ils n'ont pas laissé de cartes
et intérieurs syllabes l'accord prévoit
la wii si tu le ressens aucun abonnement
avec ses magnifiques
quelques cartons qu'on les enlève la
voilà il est bien le lcd parfait donc là
on fait la même chose que lui qui sait
passer à l'entrée c'est à dire vérifier
l'état extérieur
final voilà pareil c'est toujours la
fiche qui suit le téléphone est donc
face à va vite refait des niveaux 3 dans
sa a été réparée elle est nickel
d'accord on tour 3 chaque et plus oui
toujours il face arrière rayures oui moi
je dirais même rayures prononcer là
dessus et je voyais change la la
catégorie du dos et qui est un peu plus
payer que ce qui avait été dit ni somme
ils étaient en rade des ce qui n'est pas
terrible au gabon s'est pas fait et
maintenant ok et là il arrive en 4 g
sécu ce donc ça veut dire que tu as le
grade ars est comme neuf le grade b qui
est très bon état est grave c'est qui
est bonne et un bon rapport à votre site
ont fait moi et c'est un brutal la face
avant est nickel après à l'arrière et
qui est pas très beau mais il devrait
fonctionner je sais quoi on met une
coque de protection et on verra même pas
parfait comme ça on en raison du
problème voit la taille ça
s'allume nasser
ici c'est le contrôle qualité fait le
contrôle de groupes et donc toi tu viens
vérifier que ce qui est dit aux
différents ateliers c'est ça correspond
bien à la réalité mais voilà si vous
voulez c'est le dernier bastion avant
que le produit
ça va commercialiser ou veuves qui va
vers le client il retourne à gauche on
vient ton métier encore donc être élevés
des produits qui sont sortis gras doute
qu'ils ont été traités dans gi vais
prendre au pifomètre pourtant comme à la
maison fait notre course en tête le
shopping à l'état leur magot salue donc
récupère se produire la première des
choses que j'ai fait c'est de consulter
un petit peu l'historique et de
l'inspecteur des travaux finis voilà en
gros
mais sur du fond 12 promax donc c'est un
produit on frappe c'est plus contre
l'usure prenant ce jeu conduire contours
et se prononcer par contre le face
arrière unique n ud et comparez donc ça
veut dire que le produit en fait comme
celui là qui est comme des derniers plus
gros produit de la peur il se retrouve
en garde c'est plus parce qu'il a le
côté qui veut qu'ils critères
c'était dur comme ça c'est dur c'est
exigeant ça veut dire qu'on achète à
grasse et latin l'intrus parfaite qui
pourraient être graves ah
s'il y avait pas se manger du jeudi le
client qui va tomber sur ce produit
oui moi aussi c'est vous qui tombait
dessus bravo
[Rires]
[Musique]
wohlen iphone et ce 2020 qui a été
contrôlée par margot alors il va partir
et là je vous montrer comment ça marche
c'est moi qui vais préparer la commande
on prend quoi petites boîtes ferment
petit kit dans ce qui tient à quoi il
faut la recharger bien évidemment bloc
de charge on a le petit câble avec le
lightning on a les écouteurs ça c'est
obligatoire on prépare ça avec beaucoup
d'amour mais oui parce que l'amour c'est
très important dans la vie on vient le
glisser dedans le petit smartphone il
fait son chemin volant il vient juste
ici ces petites cailles en carton comme
ça ils bougent pas petit termes de
garanties alors j'en profite ces smart
avec 3a ya 3 ra greuil à 3 smart malin
pour retenir on la pose là on prend on
ferme et on suit la petite boîte elle
fait sa petite balade et elle part
roguet elle part pas en bateau elle part
par la poste et elle va partir ensuite
dans un sachet directement chez vous et
une fois vous avez fait votre achat si
vous avez une question ou un problème la
hotline est ici comme ça vous pouvez
avoir une personne au téléphone qui pas
loin de ceux qui reconditionnés vos
smartphones c'est un point qui peut
souvent posé question lorsqu'on vient
acheter un smartphone reconditionnés
c'est la garantie ici vous avez une
garantie de 12 à 24 mois et si jamais
vous avez un problème avec votre
smartphone d'une fa vous l'avez reçu et
bien toutes les réparations tout le sav
est géré directement ici sur ce site
dont jean-christophe toi tu es le patron
de smart c'est quoi l'histoire de la
boîte pour resituer sophie groulx et
smart est une entreprise depuis 35 ans
sur le territoire donc on est à côté de
montpellier à saint mathieu de tréviers
et ça fait 35 ans qu'on répare des
maternités décor on est des
professionnels de la maintenance de
de matériel télécoms dans notre histoire
on a on a une date qui est un petit peu
clé qui est 2011 kid est un petit peu
particulier ans et que le groupe qui
nous employé jusqu'en 2011 c'est
malheureusement écroulé et avec cinq
collègues de travail les cadres
opérationnels du site on a pu avec nos
indemnités de licenciement racheter donc
notre outil industriel et pour pouvoir
préserver l'emploi sur le territoire et
préserver la botte d'un collaborateur
est justement en termes d'emploi tu me
disais également que vous avez centre de
formation où vous former des
collaborateurs à votre métier pour
potentiellement si ça sera bien pour
tout le monde les embaucher directement
chez vous oui voilà ça fait partie un
petit peu de des engagements sociétaux
colonna on est on est des anciens
employés qui vont gâcher notre boîte et
on a donc redonné une chance
effectivement cette entreprise mais ça
fait partie aussi un petit peu des
valeurs que nous on a en tant que
dirigeant aujourd'hui de pouvoir encore
donner une deuxième chance à d'autres
personnes et effectivement donc on va
surtout chercher des personnes qui sont
petit peu loin l'emploi aux enchères de
réorientation professionnelle et on a
ouvert une école de formation qui permet
effectivement à ces personnes là après
avoir postulé auprès de nouer un
partenariat à l'épaule encore de pouvoir
intégrer sous information est suivi une
formation donc qui va leur permettre de
pouvoir savoir réparer des smartphones
remettre en état les smartphones
reconditionnés parfois vous savez tout
sur ce match
smart avec 3a qui vient reconditionnés
vos smartphones parce que les
smartphones qui viennent ce smart
proviennent à 80% de france alors c'est
vachement bien si vous voulez acheter un
smartphone reconditionnés ça a plusieurs
vertus la toute première et bien c'est
déjà donné une seconde vie voire une
troisième vie à ses smartphones donc ça
s'est super bien c'est green day co
responsable et ça va dans le sens de
l'histoire en plus de ça fait travailler
une entreprise française qui elle-même
créé des emplois en france donc voyez
ces vertueux je voudrais bien évidemment
cliquer sur le lien que vous avez en bar
en bas juste en bas dans la description
vous allez chez smart avec 3a quant à
moi je vais me faire un petit peu de
reconditionnement je suis très mauvais
je bouge de partout mais ça m à
l'exercice pour rendre un peu plus zen
sur ce je vous embrasse des bisous
prenez soin de vos gars très vite ciao
[Musique]